we're back with the amazing Meghan
Trainor and her bestie Tick Tock
sensation Chris Olson
now Chris you are single uh what are you
looking for in a guy and I have to add
this question because it's sort of as
important what are you not looking for
um I'm not looking for oh well I just
saw you share a story where you got
ghosted by someone yes I am not look I'm
looking for communication and direct
communication and because right after
that I went on a date with a guy and he
texted me a few days later and was like
you know I'm not really in a place to
date I hope you're doing well like I
hope we can be friends and I was like oh
I appreciate that like points for that
person I want the communication
um you know and love forever like a
friend the way her and Daryl are
together it's just like everything to me
okay well I hope that you can find a
match because it's time for a new
segment that we are kicking off with you
we've never done this before
[Applause]
okay we've assembled three eligible
bachelors who are here to win you over
let's meet the guys date number one is
25 years old originally from Atlanta
Georgia fun fact he collects magnets
from places he's visited very Charming
okay
is 30 years old and originally from
Memphis Tennessee fun fact he once
modeled with a human-sized bag of chips
last but certainly not least we have
data number three he's 28 years old
originally from Kansas City Missouri and
fun fact he can play several types of
saxophone
what's your question for uh Mr Number
One okay on Tick Tock I like to bring
people coffee what's your go-to coffee
order whoa Chris I think decaf coffee is
just fine with me because talking to you
already gets my heart racing
date number two what's your favorite
Meghan Trainor song and why while I do
love made you look Megan's new song
and me too I'd have to say I love me
it's a Bop
and it's all about self-empowerment
which as we know RuPaul said if you
can't love yourself how the hell are you
gonna love anybody else
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
show the audience your best Tick Tock
dance their reaction is all that matters
[Applause]
um
all right I want to ask each Bachelor
the same question which is what are you
looking for currently in your life what
are you not looking for currently in
your life I'd say I'm looking for
someone that can make me laugh and I
have a great time with and can just
really get along with my friends what
I'm not looking for is any games I'm
looking for something serious great very
thank you
same question I'd say I'm looking for
somebody really positive outgoing and
fun-loving and I'm not looking for
anybody who annoys me okay good theater
number three same question please and
thank you yes so what I'm looking for is
somebody who is willing to grow with me
and also is looking forward to like
exploring new things and understanding
where we can go as a unit but also being
able to be their own individual person
as well okay
[Music]